hi fair welcome back for another chat
about the business side of cloud
computing
happy to be back martin now i'm a
developer and i use containers every day
to make my life easier you're a business
person so i was surprised when i heard
you mention containers the other day do
business people care about containers
yes we do business leaders like things
that let them release products faster
accelerate time to market and run their
organizations more effectively how does
that break down fair
let me tell you
[Music]
all right why do business people care
about containers which is a piece of
technology after all
let's back up one step before i get into
that first business people want minimum
complexity in systems because complexity
is expensive and slow that means that
business people like service computing
and containers
and on google cloud serverless computing
plus containers means cloud run right
that's right many business people i've
talked with when first trying cloud run
to support their workloads if that works
their developers can focus on new
features instead of operations
okay and what if their workloads can't
be run serverlessly on cloud run
or if they can run on cloud run first
but they need more customization later
on
then they drop one level down in
abstraction to google kubernetes indeed
it's possible to do this because the
business logic is already in containers
which kubernetes engine can run
got it business people in tech sector
have heard about containers they like
how containers help them with technical
debt multi-cloud low utilization and
hiring those are all business problems
that's a lot fair let's break it down
you started with technical debt tell me
more about that do business people know
about technical debt many business
leaders that i've talked with have moved
their companies to the cloud but not
seeing all the benefits of the cloud
that's because they still have custom
processes for build test deployment
security availability and so on
by moving to containers they can use
standard tools and processes that way
they can get the full benefit of the
cloud
got it
next you mentioned multi-cloud
this one is pretty simple if you want to
move workloads between clouds you need a
standard deployment unit that's
containers all major cloud platforms
support them that makes sense and then
you mentioned low utilization business
people hate low utilization it means
that they
are overpaying for it infrastructure if
you are using physical machines or
virtual machines your cpu utilization is
usually pretty low
yeah that was true at my previous job
for sure
but how do containers help with
utilization when your business logic is
in containers you can scale them up and
down by deploying them on more or fewer
servers you can either let google do it
by using cloud run or you can do it by
yourself with google kubernetes engine
if you prefer
i see and last on the list was hiring
now how do containers help with that
well developers want to work with open
standards like containers so they can
get transferable skills they don't want
to become experts in custom systems that
are only used by your company so
business people know about containers
but most enterprise workloads have not
been containerized yet how should
business people think about the
container journey for their company
first of all it's fine to migrate one
application at a time
start with one application
gain experience with containers
and
with how your cloud provider handles
containers
and how should one choose a cloud
provider pk cloud provider who supports
open standards that will make everything
easier today it will also
make things easier tomorrow if you
decide to go multi-cloud
makes sense
this was a lot of business thinking you
laid on us here fair
is it written down somewhere yes
we recently published a white paper on
content from business perspective it has
way more details than i could
cover today
let's add the link into the description
right here below to this video
sounds good will do as always thanks for
sharing your business insights with us
fair
always happy to help martin
and thank you everyone for watching
check out the video description below
for the link to that full white paper we
talked about it describes the business
of containers
also if you have any questions for fair
or me please add them in the comments
and do let us know if there are other
business topics around serverless
containers cloud computing you'd like us
to bring up
until next time
you